- Aahh!
- Omega Pi Omega!
- Yeah!
- Yo, brand me, son.
- Yeah.
- Brand me, do it on my chest.
- Straight down the middle, son.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- Ahh!
- Yeah, son!
- Oh, yeah... yo...
yo, yo, hold up, man.
Come on, wait.
Wait, wait, that's...
that [bleep]'s upside-down, son.
It... it's to the side
a little bit too.
- Oh, [bleep], well,
okay, my... my bad, dog.
My bad, dog. You wanna keep
doing this [bleep]?
Let's go!
- Yeah, man.
I'm just...
I'm saying, yo, be careful.
- I got you, dog, I got you...
yeah!
- Ahh!
- What's up? That's what's up!
- Yeah.
- Straight down the middle, son!
- You can't go back
to middle now, son.
- What?
- We already committed to
the upside-down and to the side.
- I got you, dog, yeah!
- Ahh!
What are you doing, man?
- You said upside-down
and to the side.
- That's three Omegas!
- Oh, man, I forgot the Pi.
- Yeah!
- Ahh!
- Oh.
- Oh, man, I mean, you know...
that... that, man...
that... that that
could be a rocket ship,
or... or a lighthouse.
Naw, man, you straight up
got a [bleep] on your chest.
- Ahh!